Speaker 1: Well, I'm starting today with
brand new allegations of even more criminality
by the Trump crime family. Call them what you
want. This doesn't even have to do with anything
allegedly done during the administration. This has
to do with the last couple of months. Yesterday,
Congresswoman Liz Cheney, during another
installment of the January six Trump Riot
Committee hearings, announced that Donald Trump
has recently attempted to call a forthcoming
witness to try to intimidate them, presumably,
and that this has been referred to the Department
of Justice. If this is true and did Trump leave
a voicemail, we don't know the details yet. We
will get to that if this is true. This is new
alleged criminality. So let's go through it.
Axios reporting, Liz Cheney says Trump
attempted to reach out to January 6th. Witness
she said yesterday that former President Trump
personally called an unidentified January 6th
committee witness. Cheney says the committee has
referred the matter to the Department of Justice,
which has the power to
prosecute the former president
if it determines he tampered with a congressional
witness. Let's take a look at the video. This is
absolutely stunning, stunning stuff.
Speaker 2: And one more item
after our last hearing. President Trump
tried to call a witness in our investigation.
A witness you have not yet seen in these
hearings. That person declined to answer
or respond to President Trump's call and instead
alerted their lawyer to the call. Their lawyer
alerted us, and this committee has supplied
that information to the Department of Justice.
Let me say one more time. We will take any
effort to influence witness testimony very
seriously. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. I yield back.
Speaker 1: So the question, of course, is, did
Donald Trump leave a voicemail because attempted
to call the target of the call? Didn't take the
call. If you just have a missed call, it could
be argued it was someone using Trump's phone.
How did you know it was really Trump? How did you
know there was going to be an attempt to tamper
with the witness if Trump was dumb enough to leave
a voicemail? And we don't know the answer to that.
That becomes a very different story. Now, there
has been a number of you emailed me and said,
is it witness tampering if they never
actually speak to the witness? Well.
With bribery, attempting a bribe, even if
the bribe is rejected, is still a crime.
This is sort of less clear. And I looked
at different legal opinions on it. And it
there are many who say it's a crime merely
to attempt the tampering. The question is,
how can you prove there was an attempt? We just
don't know whether there's a voicemail or not.
Now, this would be shocking if it weren't so
predictable. And it's important to restate that
this is also a witness that has not been part of
the hearings yet. This is presumably a forthcoming
witness. And for Trump to personally call them
suggested someone very, very close to Trump. Now,
speculation is, could it be one of his own kids?
In which case, well, we I mean, I don't know,
maybe he's maybe he doesn't speak to his kids
very often, but maybe he does. Jason Campbell
on Twitter called the waning weeks of the Trump
administration a shockingly incompetent empire
of criminality. And if indeed the allegation
here is true that Trump personally called to
try to tamper with the witness, and by tamper
we mean influence the testimony of that's really
what we're talking about, the sort of mob boss
tactics of, listen, I know that you're going to
do the right thing and remain loyal because
you're just that type of person. Right. This is
these are the Mafia tactics that Liz Cheney
has previously said have been part of the
M.O. of the former Trump administration during the
January six committee hearings. And then the last
thing is and of course, we people are innocent
until proven guilty. There's no question of that
in the legal system, people are innocent until
proven guilty. But in the court of public opinion,
this program operates in the court of
public opinion, not in a in a legal court.
It is not the behavior of innocent people and
people with a free, clear and innocent mind
to call witnesses to try to influence their
testimony. If you believe if you know you
did nothing wrong, then you don't really have
anything to worry about. Now, you could say, well,
maybe you're worried that the witness will lie
and incriminate you. Well, that would be perjury.
That would be a crime. So stunning. Shocking
in a sense, but altogether very predictable